Okay. So, again, you get two of those.
So, he's still in Virginia, right?
So, that didn't bounce before the wall,
so he would be out. We'll keep going.
Virginia
And that hit the window which is out. So
he'd be out. Okay. And so you can kind
of see like it's never going to get back
to Chris, right? It ideally it should
but it happens. Okay. So we'll put in
the five serve rule. You got five. So
try to keep track as the server and the
person that you're serving to kind of
keeps track. There's no big thing if you
go to seven. Okay. You just keep it
around there. So you get to rotate in.
Good.
Okay. So So like like the fight if you
wait to move
till after they do their attack, you
will never be fast enough. Okay. So, as
she's as I see what she's doing, I'm
watching her and I'm watching her body
and I'm already moving that way. But,
can I just look over there? No, because
she could be faking it. So, I have to be
ready to go the other way. Okay. So, I
although we start you in a line after he
calls the line, you do not have to stay
in that line. No one said that. You guys
all just did that on your own. Okay,
continue.
Continue.
[Music]
And so we didn't hit the wall the B the
mat first. So that would have been out.
Okay. Is it making sense? Okay. Um
and then there's no bing.
You're not punching someone in the face,
but we're not going to be Charlie on the
mat. So, just to share with my mindset
when I'm in Virginia's, you're out.
You're going to be out and you because
he's going to set me up perfectly and
I'm going to make it so hard that it'll
be harder for the next person and the
next person. Okay? So, really the worst
place to be is third.
Then the the super absolute worst place
to be is third behind me. Okay? That's
how That's how your mind should be.
Okay. All right. We're We're in play.
All the rules and exercises are in
effect
out. And then you just keep cycling. Get
back in the line. Exercise.
Don't worry about those till we get in
between. So, what happened there? The
window. Okay. Hit
the window.
Got to get your body.
You got to stand. Okay. Wait, stand by.
To come in, we would say Angelo.
You say Travis, Virginia in Virginia in
Rio. Andrew,
Derek,
Rio, Derek,
get your body in the right place to
Maya.
Come on, Miles.
That's too
Chris.
So Chris got called last and Chris goes
to the back.
Maya Chris
[Applause]
[Music]
Maya knows she she grew up from a little
kid right by side. Okay. So she came
this way, saw him going that way and
then went the other way. So you have to
read the opponent. What's Ronnie telling
you? Okay. And so this way you can It
was an effortless hit because he got so
deep into the other angle. Okay. Keep
going. Angelo win. Maya Angelo.
Coordination on both sides. in. Let's go
up to 10 serves. 10 serves
five
more notches.
My uh
Okay, that's I hate to say it, but you
got to pick your opponent. Older people
with bad knees have a hard time on the
low ball. Okay, remember I was telling
you that in the kids game. Remember that
Charlie is not going to do. So you pick
your opponent who's showing mobility,
who's not showing mobility. Okay, go.
Maya, Derek,
Virginia,
Maya. Virginia.
It didn't bounce inside, but that was
out.
Maya Virginia.
Hit the ball directly. Andrew,
Maya, Andrew.
Nope, he's out. He pushed the ball. You
always got to hit it.
So either I start with
Did it hit the window? Did it hit the
wall? Did it hit the window? Then you're
out. You can't hit the window.
[Music]
the wall directly.
No, he didn't call you.
What happened? I thought you said no.
You didn't call. That doesn't mean the
ball stops. You're out there.
Chris,
you got to get into
And you got to hit it. Yeah.
Ryan,
[Music]
try this invis.
Did that make it or no? Okay,
Travis.
A
trying to Come on.
There.
There you go.
Got to keep the window in awareness even
if you're not looking at it.
[Music]
Andrew
Chris
[Music]
touching Angelo
Derek.
[Music]
You're good. You say loud. Say it loud.
No.
That's not interference.
Okay. So, yep.
You got you got to be obstructed by him.
That's where the spine spine rule comes
in. Okay. He got out of the way. You
went around him. Okay, go
in.
Ryan got
Travis in
Angelo. Travis.
Yeah, but you weren't in line at the
start.
Andrew. Andrew.
window.
So, someone counted that Virginia hit
the window sill as a cow, but that's not
the wall. The wall is this way. So, you
have to hit the wall.
Rio Chris,
you're moving.
Derek,
where you
all right? So couple things just be
aware of propioception.
So propioception is I know where I am in
space. Okay. Um so wherever I'm at I I
don't know which I'm not looking at it.
Okay. But when we get target focus which
we will get task focus your awareness
will go in. You'll lose the
propioception. That's how surprised I
hit the window. The window is not moving
the same place at the beginning of the
game. Okay. Another thing is um
your weapon selection is going to be
dependent upon hopefully I can set it up
just right. But if I can't then you
can't use that weapon anymore and that
weapon's going to jack you up. Your
weapon selection is ultimately what's my
desire but where did I get to what they
give me. So let's say you're in a bad
position. You had this great slice
you're going to do right but I lost the
window. I'm too close for the slice.
just take the same box so I stay in.
Okay. Stay in the fight versus losing
it. All right. So, I'll point those out
as it's happening. So, keep an eye on
the window. Make sure you're not looking
at it. Rio tracks.
Rio Angelos.
Good. That's a safe shot.
Okay, now that wall is easy for you to
hit,
but we're just unconsciously keeping it
over here. My job is to make it hard for
them to hit. So, if I keep hitting it
over here, there's no people to get
through. While I'm heading over even a
shot off of here, I hit it over here.
She's got to get through all these
people. All these people are all in the
way. Okay. Another thing, the wall is
predictive.
You can see how the ball's going to
angle. How much force you can predict.
The weapons is not predictable. If I hit
the It's easy for me to hit the weapons.
It's hard for him to hit a ball off the
weapons. Okay. We're confusing what's
easy for us with what's hard for them.
They're not the same. Okay. Try it
again.
video Derek
Rio
propioepp
[Applause]
My dad.
Okay.
Virginia.
Say it. Say it loud. This one they can
hear cuz the fan got it up.
Angel in Derek.
Take the easy shot. What's out of
position?
[Music]
in
Christ.
Okay.
So Sean,
you got to remember Sean
Kristen.
President
[Music]
Christmas.
Okay. Why I first strategy was give them
more things to think about. So change of
pace, hit the fan. It's a slightly
harder shot. You don't know if your mind
can do it right. I've got to keep these
shots. Always be aggressive.
Chris, Virginia.
Virginia
Right in the other line.
Make one way. Go the other way.
Go the other way.
Don't end up
[Music]
Sean in
G. Sean.
Dr. Andrew
Krista.
[Music]
Stay there.
Who's got that? Did you make it? Who
made it? The person behind me
there.
Sean in the business. Kate is changing
three the same one over there then
another K is changing
Sean
[Music]
behind
Sean
is
Ryan
Kristen, Chris.
[Music]
Okay, hurry up.
So that would be an interference. Is
that your second?
Probably not. Probably not. So you're in
where you are.
Virginia
to Virginia.
Sean.
So that would be inter.
Did everyone see how I did that?
Chris is I was behind the ball. I can't
go can't go like this.
So I know he has one now.
Now I try for the second.
You do too, David. Sean,
get off the big wall. Get off the big
wall.
Again,
that shot is much harder than it looks,
okay? Because it looked over there
since the ball has
shot.
See how it stops? See how it stops
right
Did you make it?
Did you make it? Okay. So, what do you
use?
Change the tempo. Take one leg and
unpredictable surface. Okay.
Yeah. Where are we? This is going to be
Chris.
[Music]
You also have a bathroom. I was
wondering why you can't change
elevations.
Okay, we're not going to lie. All right,
Jeremy
on Derek.
[Music]
I think that was
Caroline.
Derek to fire
[Applause]
in
there.
How you doing?
Okay.
Nice. Take that, Chris.
All right. Excellent.
Yes.
Holy
Okay, stay
[Music]
two.
So again, while the server is not
supposed to get anywhere now,
get
Oh, one of my hands. Open up.
[Music]
Get in line so we can see. Don't touch
me. The ball can't go in play till the
line is called.
Okay. Virginia to Angela.
[Music]
Virginia to Angela.
Complicate the ball. Complicate the
ball.
[Applause]
Nice.
Hey, Virginia to Andrew.
[Music]
Virginia to
be ready.
Virginia to accurate.
So now you all know the ball does that.
I want to overshoot. I shoot. Okay. You
know the opponent does that, right? All
right. Virginia.
Virginia
[Music]
too deep in your office.
Virginia
[Applause]
Virginia to Derek
Ryan
to Ryan.
Virginia two J.
So obviously moving towards
a cluster girl out of position. What
defense do you have that you can use? Do
over. didn't have to hit the bad ball.
Just don't don't take it till it's a
easy shot.
And I'm going to go out.
Okay. But but you can see that's how we
build awareness. You see, I got close to
him and no. Okay. And that's how we
start with the awareness at the level.
All right. Um then as it gets higher,
you know, it's with the stuff, but good.
Okay, don't don't let things keep up on
you. All right. Um, you have all these
additional ways of getting people out,
complicate things, all that kind of
stuff. Okay. Stop making the easy shot
where you're just being Charlie and
worried about can I make my shot. Yes.
Make your shot to get the next person
out. You can figure out how to get the
person in front of you. All right. It's
all possible. All right. Here we go.
Rio, Virginia.
That one's out.
After
the wall
in
tennis.
I don't know why
it impossible.
My uh Chris,
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
All right. You want your opponent going
to try for that second one over here
now? Okay.
Go. They want
Maya. Ryan.
Maya, Ryan,
Travis,
can't wait till we're here to get there.
Maya, Travis, got to leave the body.
Leave the body.
Maya Chris
Maya Chris.
Very good.
[Music]
Nice.
Only do the safe shot if you're out of
position for a kill shot. Be aggressive.
Angela
proper section. All right. Uh penalty
exercises. cuz there's double.
So, 20 push-ups and 10 chin-ups. You'll
just take a break between the chin-ups.
Okay. Sean,
Chris and
Chris Travis.
Ah, wait. So, Virginia made it, right?
But then the ball hitter, that's only
interference. She's not out unless it's
her second one.
What? Wait, what weirdness is going on
back there? Get in line. What happened?
I forgot one place. Ah, then you're out.
Sensei's rule. Lots of awareness.
That didn't hit. That was too
[Music]
Sean.
Good. Good.
Okay. Now server doesn't server does 10
but goes to the box not to
Virginia.
Uh, I don't think so.
You have to push it closer to the ball.
Yes, sir. You understand that? Yes. If
that if that if that ball is like way
over there,
you got to show I'm running. It would
look like this. You're You're not You're
here.
Okay. You got to make some serious
effort. He has to try to get out of it.
Go.
You're running at the end, Angel. You
got to be ready before he he hits it.
There it is.
Come on. Wake up. Where's your mind? I'm
going to kill James, but daddy
smile.
[Laughter]
You're very
I don't know. You don't look very aware.
You're out.
Chris, how are you?
Yes. Yes.
Did it make it? I I don't know. It
bounced on. Where did I
It was on the sill. Okay. Out.
The bouncing part was fine.
[Music]
Start playing against their bodies. You
already know who left.
Sean in
a shot.
[Applause]
[Music]
You need a dress.
So, who's got a left hand?
Not who owns one.
Who who can go to the right or the left?
No, you can't because you're making
these crazy shots. They're over here and
you're going like that. Who can change
levels?
You can't.
Who waits till I hit the ball?
Okay. So, if I if the person behind me
waits till they hit the ball, what
should I probably hit the ball to do?
What should I How should I hit it? along
the long away from them. Okay? They're
not going to get there on time. All
right. If someone's favoring the right
where they're doing a weird shot with
that right hand and you're noticing
that, fake right, go left. Got it. Okay.
You see the people who are constantly
trying to run like this instead of
dropping their center. Okay. That's a
baby shot. There's a baby shot. Okay.
Start start attacking the person, not
just what you can get away with. Orient
direct aid to your attack. Go.
So you chased out that guy didn't get to
that baby shot.
[Music]
Sorry. I'm out.
I would take the people that lose
propriception over to the windows
always.
Chris
[Music]
has that target fixation. Okay.
Can't push the ball.
Chris
Andrew.
You hit it right.
Wow.
Remember, it's not going to bounce. It's
always going to back spin. It just kind
of goes up. Maybe even the other way.
There you go. Oh, you see now? Okay. So,
he feels bad. But we're not pulling
back.
[Music]
You guys understand that? But
somebody somebody you know basically
said, "Who standing still? Do the cross
shot. You're not going to get there." Do
you understand? How hard was that cross
shot? Not hard at all. Wasn't fast. In
other words, it wasn't low or anything.
It's just a long way to to distance. And
then my ability, my offense just gets so
compromised because of how I wanted to
set it up. And now I win. I'm cheating.
You get it? You do understand? And then
it can't be on us to go like I'm not I'm
not doing that. Yes, that's what we're
doing here. Okay, this is not sparring,
but it is sparring. Okay, so we're good
to go. So, let's keep going. Come on in.
It shouldn't take this long or this be
this difficult to get someone out. Where
where are you at, Rio?
Okay, then leave the use those out. Go
back in and play. Leave the exercises
in. Great shot.
Ryan awareness.
[Music]
Good change.
Ah, good. Very nice.
So you take note that guy hits the
windows a lot.
[Music]
That was good.
James Maya.
Yeah.
[Music]
Go left hand. I don't know. Maybe maybe
not.
Wait,
where did that do? I don't think that
made it. It spun off. It spun off the
the Does anybody think it made it?
Duo. We'll do a duo.
But I'm going to take notes. I'm going
to go. I don't think that guy knows what
he's going to do.
So if I give him a lot of options to
choose from, we'll probably get stuck on
one. Okay. And we're working on the
other ones available. So I take note.
[Music]
Whoever was next was supposed to
let you go by.
Yeah, you did make it
James.
[Music]
Last ball.
Okay.